diese 31 august das ist der tag an dem
lady dabei starb der tragischer
autounfall in paris das war genau auf
den tag genau vor 25 jahren am tag an
dem tatsächlich die welt für einen
moment still stand
so kennen wir sie so bleibt sie in einer
lady di die schöne prinzessin mit dem
tragischen schicksal
am frühen morgen des 31
august 1997 rüttelt eine nachricht die
welt auf die so unglaublich scheint dass
sie eigentlich gar nicht wahr sein kann
ich bin morgens wach geworden mit dem
radiowecker den gab es damals noch und
da war die nachricht da jänner tot und
nicht mehr hoch geschnellt und kapierst
du es gar nicht in dem moment also man
denkt es kann jetzt nicht sein also da
war tiefe traurigkeit tiefe
betroffenheit nicht nur bei mir ich da
bei jedem damals mit dem ich gesprochen
habe als man konnte das gar nicht fassen
was da passiert ist ich erinnere mich
dass ich wirklich glaube fünf tage fast
rund um die uhr ein ohr an diesen
weltempfänger haben und habe jedes jede
sekunde dieser berichterstattung auf bbc
world service verfolgt habe so grausam
ihr tod so glanzvoll war ihre
erscheinung zu lebzeiten eine ikone
ihrer zeit bis heute verehrt geliebt und
mystifiziert also ich bin ja nur zweimal
begegnet es gibt menschen die betreten
einen raum und der raum richtet sich wie
so kleine magnet nadeln alles richtet
sich auf sie und sie hatte sie hatte
diese im maggi diese mischung aus
verletzlichkeit und stärke das hatte sie
die spuren ihres kurzen faszinierenden
lebens lassen sich bis heute besonders
in london finden die engländer gedenken
schon seit tagen ihrer prinzessin der
herzen vor allem ihr langjähriger
prunkvoller wohnort wird zur
wallfahrtsstätte
hier in kensington palace lebte lady
diana während ihrer ehe und auch nach
der scheidung von prinz charles und das
ist auch der ort an dem ihre söhne prinz
harry und prinz william aufwuchsen wie
man sieht an dieses tor werden immer
noch sehr viele fotos und auch hosen
gelegt und es ist eine der haupt
gedenkorte für daniela die königin der
herzen oder hier in england auch besser
gesagt die peoples princess ihr
spitzname oder ihr kosename der eben ihr
großes herz und auch ihre große
wohltätigkeit gegenüber ihrer
mitmenschen ausdrückt und zeigt geboren
1961 als diana spencer als drittes von
vier kindern eine höhere tochter aus
gutem hause prinz charles lernt sie
keineswegs zufällig kennen angeblich
weiß sie schon mit dreizehn da sie ihn
heiraten will
soviel ich weiß hat charles
besucht dass das den stammsitz des
panzers und
hat so glaube ich kurz gedatet wie
ältere schwester und da war damals noch
sehr sehr jung zum 13 14 und hat sich
hat sich auch in fakuma angeblich hat
sich schon sehr früh in den kopf gesetzt
die will ich mir schnappen hat und hat
sich so zu sagen da hat davon geträumt
ihrer älteren schwester den thronfolger
aus zu auszuspannen hat die aller ersten
videoaufnahmen danas 1980 lassen erahnen
welche bilder schlacht um das neue
mitglied der königlichen familie
entstehen wird da wird zur
meistfotografierten frau der welt
[Musik]
prinzessin der jänner war von tag eins
an eine ikone und sie ist es auch 25
jahre nach ihrem tod immer noch und was
in meinen augen ganz wichtig ist dafür
dass hier eine ikone ist sind die fotos
also diese magischen momente die fotos
die es von ihr gab und dieses von ihr
gibt und die sind im kopf drin die
hochzeit der kuss auf dem balkon und sie
hat mit john travolta getanzt also das
ist auch eines der ersten fotos
überhaupt und sie hat tatsächlich am
nächsten morgen nachdem sie einen termin
wahrgenommen hat die zeitungen sehr
genau durch geschaut ob sie auf seite
eins ist und sie hatte wirklich zum teil
das hatten wir diese person erzählt die
sie erlebt hat dann frühstück die
zeitungen durchgecheckt und wenn sie
nicht bei jeder zeitung auf seite eins
war
war sie quasi beleidigt oder oder erbost
darüber oft kam das allerdings nicht vor
denn die schlagzeilen rund um die
prinzessin von wales reisen niemals ab
[Musik]
1988 trifft die berühmteste frau der
welt dann den damals wohl berühmtesten
mann der welt angeblich hat michael
jackson bei einem konzert sogar extra
auf seinen hit dirty diana verzichtet um
die prinzessin nicht in verlegenheit zu
bringen hat von anfang an mit den medien
gespielt und sie hat natürlich auch mit
dem fotografen gespielt und auch ganz
genau gewusst wie sie sich zu
inszenieren hat genau gewusst welcher
blick jetzt gewünscht ist sie hat sich
natürlich auch genau so angezogen wie
sie wusste dass die fotografen
ausflippen vor begeisterung wenn der
jänner kommt und natürlich wurde das
immer mehr immer mehr immer mehr an am
ende war das gar nicht mehr steuerbar
zur ruhe kommt sie zu hause hinter
verschlossenen türen mit ihren kindern
und in ihrem lieblingscafé im
romantischen stadtteil notting hill
das café diana erhielt seine bedeutung
und seinen namen eigentlich durch zufall
als besitzer aktuell ende der 80er jahre
dieses café eröffnete er das lady die
mit ihren kindern hier am nordeingang
des kensington palace ganz raus kam und
benannte deshalb das café nach der
königin der herzen und diese kam
tatsächlich auch selbst sehr oft zu
besuch hat sich ihr frühstück mit ihren
kindern und ja man kann sehen es
befinden sich zahlreiche cafés und
aufnahmen der prinzessin vier unter
anderem das erste bild das die besitzer
ab du selbst übergab
1989 und mit ihrem autogramm versah und
ja so wirklich hier das maßgeblich
prägte das dass der place to be für alle
der jenaer fans ist in ihrem geliebten
garten des kensington palast zweiten
ihre söhne letztes jahr eine neue dna
statue ein und was bleibt noch von ihr
25 jahre nach ihrem tod und sie war
sicher eine große modernisiererin sie
war jemand der den menschen das gefühl
gegeben hat das königshaus ist nahbarer
was allerdings eine verhängnisvolle
folge war dass sie das königshaus ein
bisschen in so eine soap-opera
verwandelt hat und davon ist das
königshaus bis heute nicht frei das war
ja ein absoluter tabubruch im königshaus
also gefühle wurden niemals nach außen
getragen sie hat das gemacht und hat
sich damit ja auf die ebene des ganz
normalen volkes begeben
baba und doch unerreichbar
eine nachfolgerin wird es in dieser
dimension wohl so schnell nicht geben da
jena bleibt einzigartig und gerade
deswegen millionen menschen so gut in
erinnerung
der fünfundzwanzigste todestag von lady
di und unsere bild reporterin julia
winczewski in london ja sie denkt heute
ganz besonders an lady di und tut das
mit den allen briten dort wie gedenkt
man dort heute leben hier
ist es ja gerade erste kurz nach sechs
also fast halb sieben und man sieht
schon im hintergrund vor kensington
palace sind die ersten royalen fans dich
hier auch heute tribut zollen an lady 3
und eben sich an sie erinnern und wie
man schon in dem beitrag vorher gehört
hat sie war die königin der herzen auf
englisch typus princess und das merkt
man jetzt auch schon eben das zu dieser
frühen uhrzeit bereits leute herkommen
um fotos aufzuhängen um rosen nieder zu
legen und ja das ist schon
außergewöhnlich muss man sagen dass sie
das als reales mitglied hier geschafft
hat immer noch nach all diesem jahr nach
25 jahren nach ihrem tod so in
erinnerung zu bleiben was würden die
briten zuallererst sagen also welche
eigenschaft was würden sie ihr zuerst zu
schreiben was es das wort das lady day
aus dem blick der briten am allerbesten
beschreibt
ich glaube volksnah und herzlich
herzlich nach 25 jahren nach dem tod das
über sie zu sagen über sie zu hören das
ist eine tolle eigenschaft jetzt gibt es
aber doch schon wieder ein skandal im
britischen königshaus auch rund um
diesen 25 todestag der wirt vermasselt
von medien
ja also wir haben gehört lady di hat
selbst immer die titelseiten durchsucht
nach fotos von sich und heute wäre sie
da enttäuscht weil wie man hierbei bis
ansieht
megan und sind mägen und harry zu sehen
und es wird getitelt major soft illusion
ja wir haben wieder einmal royales drama
aber nicht mich hier in erinnerung an
lady day sondern tatsächlich in
aktuellster situation um mehr gehen die
ja gerade das cover von dem
amerikanischen magazin hat ziert und ja
da für jede menge gesprächsstoff sorgt
weil sie ein sehr
kritisches interview gegeben hat wo sie
auch wieder einige hinweise darauf gibt
wie es um die beziehung zwischen harry
und sein vater steht zwischen prinz
charles und ihm eben und auch um ihr
eigenes verhältnis zur englischen königs
haben also medien drängt sich in den
vordergrund an diesem 25
todestag von lady di dann kann unsere
bild reporterin julia winczewski dort
von kensington palast
[Musik]